hello everybody
there's a lot of feedback happening i'm
sorry um okay
so i'm chris martens i'm a grad
student at carnegie mellon university in
pittsburgh
in the computer science department there
so i'm still an academic i haven't
recovered yet
and i'm really happy to be here at
strange loop this is my first one
to tell you about linear logic
programming which is sort of the basis
of my
phd research okay so this is just to
give you a parse on the title of my talk
it's kind of a word level portmanteau
of the concepts of linear logic and
logic programming
um and i'm going to sort of assume
at least a little bit of familiarity
like maybe you've seen or heard of
logic programming um which i mean to be
broadly queries on sets of rules but
that linear logic may be a more
unfamiliar concept linear logic is just
a
variance on propositional logic that's
good at dealing with resources
at least at a very sentence-level brush
and the key point of this talk basically
is that a system based on linear logic
programming is really good for
expressing what i'm going to call
locally stateful computation
in a declarative fashion so what i mean
by locally stateful
is that you're trying to model some
evolving system like maybe you're trying
to describe
the space of allowable moves in a board
game or something
and your state consists of a bunch of
stuff so you've got all of the cells of
the board game
you've got maybe some other global
properties of the game that you're
tracking like whose turn it is and
whether certain pieces have moved yet or
whatever
um and you're when you're operating on
the level of a single move in the game
you're really only interested in certain
properties um
changing and you know for instance if
you're moving upon you only really want
to care about
the square that that piece is on and the
squares
sort of directly adjacent to it that it
wants to move to
this is sometimes described as a frame
property
in other settings
so i'm an ivory tower academic like i
said um i
this is going to be a pretty theoretical
talk i hope that's okay
um i the research group i'm in is called
the principles of programming
um so you know the first sort of obvious
thing that i hope you get out of this is
that maybe
there are some broadly applicable
concepts to whatever you're working on
or if you happen to do research whatever
you're researching
the second is that there is an
implementation of these ideas
um i wouldn't exactly call it an
emerging language it's kind of a happy
hermit
of a language uh called self which is
kind of just a really bare-bones
implementation of the these ideas just
to kind of play with them but i
think it's really fun and a neat thing
to use
and extend potentially in the future
which is my third point um i i want to
to see how these ideas can grow into
something like maybe a library like
corelogic
is used in closure for logic programming
maybe something like that
where it can be used as an embedded
language and in a more
fully featured setting um or
another another way of possibly
positioning this in the future is
as a scripting language um or some some
other part of
a part of your tool kit for a
development process
okay so back to this idea of locally
stateful computation
just like a very kind of naive gloss of
things
just to give you some idea of what i'm
talking about in terms of
you may be more familiar with there's
kind of uh there's a purely functional
way of of processing of dealing with
state like this
um which is just to pass the entire
state around
through your function calls so this is
just sort of the standard way of doing
functional programming with big data
structures um
of course there are ways to improve on
this but this is
the naive way of doing it in the
imperative setting
if in the imperative setting we can
just do this direct kind of in place
sorry
replacement of some state with some
other state
which is which is the the notion of
locally stateful
computation that i'm describing but
what linear logic programming gives us
is a declarative approach to that
and declarative is an awfully fuzzy word
um so
let me try to be more precise about what
i mean um
so i'll start by giving you another
fuzzy word which is high level
okay what i mean by that is that there
is a really close match
between the ideas that you're trying to
represent like the
state of your system and the constructs
that are available to you in the
language so i really want
there to be a direct mapping
between those things and the second
thing i mean by declarative is that it's
informed by logical principles
i really like logic and i happen to
think that it's a great way of sort of
organizing
your ideas to design a language
in the first place it has a lot of good
guiding principles so that we know
when we've gotten things right so
that's why i like logic programming okay
so what do i mean by logic programming
the analogy that i love to use to
explain logic programming
is that proof search is execution of a
program
um so we you have some program
that just is describing some
i am worried that i got these slides out
of order i
might just be missing some okay gonna
run with it
uh okay so a logic program is a set of
rules and a query so the thing
on the box to the left is the set of
rules
anything in the box to the right is a
query and
these rules the syntax of this rules
just says uh just say that
there's a rule called rule one which
establishes a of foo
from no assumptions so that's an axiom
there's a rule called rule 2
which establishes b of x from a of x
where x ranges over anything it's
universally quantified that's what this
symbol for all x accents
and a query is something that you can
run after you've written the program
you can ask the program to
you can ask the program is this thing
true you can say
is b of x true and really what that
means is for sum x is there some value
that you could put there that would make
the thing succeed
and if it can it might succeed in a
variety of ways but if it can it will
give you
a value for that x for in this case foo
and if it fails it will tell you that
it's failed and
in addition to giving you an answer
what's the value of x
you also get a proof which is just this
composition
of rule 1 and rule 2. demonstrating
that
okay so here's a
sort of more realistic example but still
quite small example
of how to use proof searches computation
again this is just sort of prolog style
logic programming so this is review if
you've seen that
at least in terms of the way the program
is written so this is a program that
computes graph connectivity and we have
a rule that says if there's an edge
in our graph of x to y then there's a
path from x to y so that's one rule
defining path
and there's a path transitivity rule
which says if we have
a an edge from x to y and then that's
some intermediate point y
the path from y to z then we get the
composed path
from x to z and
when we want to encode some test program
like this linear graph that goes a b c d
that's uh we're able to encode that as
just um
yet more rules in our system and in
particular
as axioms that don't require anything
where we establish that there's
these edge predicates between a b
b c and c d
all right so there are if we wanted to
think about this idea of proof search um
how we would implement it they're kind
of two complementary ways of talking
about it and these aren't mutually
exclusive
but um but they can be sort of explained
as separate strategies
um and these are i'll call them backward
chaining and forward chaining
and if we run some query this question
mark dash
syntax again is what i'm using for
queries uh if we run a query
trying to search for some goal then in
the backward chaining setting
we'll look at that goal and we'll start
working upward we'll start saying
which rules in my program
match that goal and then try to solve
recursively for those sub goals
forward chaining um so that's the way
the prologue works so
forward chaining is kind of an
alternative approach where
you start by just looking at your
program you look at the axioms that you
already have
and you start propagating forward just
trying to
fire your reasoning at everything in
sight until um
until it doesn't make sense to anymore
and then you stop and you see
whether there's anything in your context
that matches the goal
so this is
this is an illustration of in particular
how forward training works
and i'm going to i wish i had some way
to
slow reveal sorry about that uh so
the query if we run a query on our
graph connectivity program searching for
the query path a x or x again is this
existentially quantified variable um
this is supposed to return to us all of
the
values um all of the things that are
reachable from a
right so what forward chaining does is
we give it that query and it's like okay
that's nice i don't care
um i'm just going to look at the program
and first pull out all of the edge facts
and throw them into something that i'm
going to call a database
then we want to apply every rule that
can apply to those facts
to everything in our database so we add
in
the path facts corresponding to each of
those edges
and along the way maybe we notice that
there's already an answer to our
solution
but um we we then do this again where we
generate the path facts
that now can be generated from the
previous edge facts and the new path
facts which gives us
the two hop away
connectivity and then we keep doing this
until
what i call saturation which is the
point at which
applying some rule in our system would
not tell us
any new information anything that we
don't already have in our database
at saturation then we can go back and
look through and we can notice
that b c and d are all values of x that
make that true okay
so why i've told you that prologue which
is kind of the most
popular successful and logic programming
language
um it uses backward chaining so why
would we care about forward chaining
people care about it for different
reasons um this is just a little bit of
context for it
david mcallister has proven some
complexity results for certain classes
of programs that
just work a lot better using the forward
chaining approach
like for example the program i just
showed you um you get a kind of
memoization for free by
by eagerly computing all of these sub
programs um
and as opposed to the backward chaining
approach where you recompute them
for everything that shares a sub problem
um in the so in the database community
there's a there's a system called data
log
which is kind of a generalization of sql
and i don't know that much about it but
i know people like it um and what i'm
actually
interested in why i'm interested in
forward chaining
is because i want to be able to model
evolving systems
um so to explain how we get from
the forward training that i showed you
before
to how you'd use it to model an evolving
system um i want to look at
a little bit more carefully at this way
that i'm thinking of rules as
propositions in a logic so previously i
was
writing rules with two premises
and a conclusion like this and you can
think of that as a
as a formula in first order logic so if
i can just read the read the syntax if
you're not familiar with it that says
for all x a of x and b of t implies
c of x and t um
and these connectives says for all
implies and and
um are connected in first order logic
and and this this is sort of
the ambient logic in our system which i
will call the host logic
that's kind of just to distinguish
between the fact that
when we're writing down systems in a
logic programming language
those themselves can kind of that system
can be kind of thought of as a logic as
like the object logic that we're
encoding
and i'm differentiating that from the
host logic
so the idea of this talk is basically to
replace the host logic or at least add
to the host logic
constructs from this other logic called
linear logic
all right so i'm going to explain linear
logic by sort of contrasting it to
the typical notion of logic that you
may have seen before so persistent or
truth-based logic is kind of what we
care about as human reasoners
right so we're you know trying to learn
things about the world
and we know that someone tells us that
gravity causes things to fall
and then we separately learn that
gravity exists
so we cleverly deduce that things can
fall but we don't forget that gravity
exists we just
add that to our store of knowledge that
we're accumulating
this makes sense because these things
are thought of as facts that never
change never go away
um linear logic is resource based so
instead of facts we have things like a
dollar or a snack
um that are more like things that we
spend that get consumed
so there's an analogous con concept of
implication with this lolli symbol
and and with this tensor symbol except
that they kind of mean different things
when we're thinking of our logical atoms
as resources rather than facts so in
this in this system it's like if you
have some way like a vending machine
of turning a dollar into a snack and you
also have a dollar
then you can get a snack but you don't
get to keep the dollar sorry
okay so from the logic programming side
view
um i had been describing the way that
the system
the forward chaining system evolves um
as like a database
and so you know it's like you're running
around with a notepad you're like an
alien you're trying to learn things and
you have this notepad and you write down
the fact that the gravity exists
okay and then you also have this
inference that gravity causes things to
fall
so you add you write down things fall at
the bottom so your database is
monotonically increasing is kind of the
mathy word for that
it's just it just keeps growing um
instead in
if we if we think of this proposit if
this rule is like a
for turning a dollar into a snack as a
linear logic
uh proposition and we want to kind of
change the state along that proposition
then
um well we have a dollar and maybe some
pocket lint in our pocket and maybe we
have another dollar too
and when we change that state via that
rule well we should
replace one of our dollars with a snack
but everything else kind of stays the
same including that other dollar that we
didn't spend
all right so i've talked about the
way that we um use linear logic notation
to conjoin
um two resources a tensor b and
a lolli b means basically replace a with
b
there are two other connectives that are
important in this logic
bang a is the way that we refer back to
something
that's persistent so we can still
recover all of the stuff that has to do
with facts as well
and then there's a just a symbol bold
one that just means the nothing
resource the empty resource
and i've so far described both forward
and backward chaining
and persistence and linear logic and all
combinations of these things make sense
but specifically for this talk i'm going
to just kind of by by convention by
virtue of the examples i'm working with
use backward chaining predicates
for persistent things and forward
chaining predicates for linear things
and again that's
that bottom last cell is really kind of
what i'm interested in because that's
what lets us
model these evolving systems um
everything with a green check mark in it
is available and supported in itself it
doesn't really have good support for
doing persistent forward chaining but
that is something that's
available in data log
okay so now i just want to try to give
you a bunch of examples
of like how would you actually write and
run a program like this
what that would give you um and then
just try to expose you to a bunch of the
a bunch of examples so that it gets in
your head a little bit
and by the way everything in this talk
is is
runnable or at least there's a version
of it that i've coded up all these
examples so if you want to like
find me afterwards and see the way the
system actually looks
that would be fine too okay so my first
example is sorting
and in particular i'm going to talk
about a sort of
silly sorting other algorithm where we
want it to be in place
and we we basically just want to do it
by looking anywhere where there's
a pair of adjacent things that are out
of order
and then just swap them so we want to
like reach
in anywhere into like the middle of our
array notice that 10 and 3 are out of
order and swap them
okay so the first thing that we're going
to write in our logic program just looks
like straightforward
persistent uh backward chaining so
standard kind of prologue style
definitions where we have these
adjacency facts
establishing which locations are
adjacent and we have a recursively
defined
predicate on numbers that defines when
one is
when something is less than another
thing natural numbers
and now we can actually write a sorting
program in one line
um okay so the way this works so this is
a
forward-chaining linear rule so we
consume um the fact that
n is at the location l and then we
notice
using the backward chaining predicate
for adjacency the
l is adjacent to l prime and then we see
we also consume the fact that n prime is
in l prime and we notice that
n prime is less than l prime okay so the
things i've said we've consumed
those now go away and they get replaced
with what comes after the lolly
which is now we put an n prime at l
and um the n at l prime
so just literally just reordering
the two components of the array only
writing down
again this is important like only
writing down the bits that
we cared about
okay but how do we actually use this to
like run a program so just a tiny
example so if we have
locations um l1 l2 l3
and we have 321 then we can write a
query now this is a
sort of a different form of query than i
was showing you before
because we actually have to write it as
an implication
and the reason for that is because these
um these at
atoms these things that say which values
are at which locations those can change
those are linear
resources so if we just wrote them down
in our program they'd be taken as axioms
and considered
persistent so we kind of have to preload
our initial state
by writing it all to the left of lolly
and then
we can say now at the end of
um at the end of that forward chaining
phase i expect
there to be similar predicates in in the
in the state um i'm going to be using
the word
state where i was using database before
so
the state of linear proof search
so i expect the my state at the end of
at the end of proof search to look like
this where
x1 and x2 and x3 can range over whatever
they happen to be at the end
and instead of
talking about saturation like i had
previously done for forward chaining
i'm going to talk about quiescence which
is analogous but
in in terms of linear logic it doesn't
make sense to say
just because if we fire a rule we get
something that we already have in our
database don't fire it because we might
still want to fire it because extra
copies can help us
extra you know instances of one dollar
are different from one
instance of a dollar so instead um we
stopped doing linear forward chaining
when there just are no more rules that
can fire
okay um and you might notice that in
this example there are actually
two locations starting out where this
swap rule that we've written applies
so there are two there are two adjacent
things that are out of order
um and in again in the persistent
view of the world of forward chaining uh
we would just be doing both of them
anyway
and it wouldn't matter which order we
did them in but in in linear logic
linear logic changes the world so when
we apply some linear rule
we we may not be able to apply the other
one again so we have to actually pick
which one
and the wave itself does this um the the
sort of
semantics that we've decided to give
this is just that it's non-deterministic
it just picks one
okay so this means that there are
actually two different ways that this
sorting uh that the sort could happen
so we could first swap two and three and
then
one and three and then one and two or we
could swap one and two
and then three and two uh sorry three
and one and then three and two and then
two and three
and all of the the things in teal are
kind of just carried through because
they're not
those are the the frame part of the
frame property that i was mentioned
mentioning they don't matter to the rule
when we're applying them
um in terms of the actual software
you get something that represents sort
of that graph i just showed you
in a more kind of lambda calculus
notation
like that sort of thing that's what we
have uh so
and and this is this is literally just a
a pro i mean it's
it's a proof um exactly recording
the way that proof search happened in
the system
and it basically just
shows you if you kind of read down the
the right-hand side of the equal sign
which rules were applied and then the
variables that it's applying to
give you this ability to kind of track
the dependency throughout the
computation
um from the ones that were generated so
so when we apply swap to like x1 and x2
then that gives us you know some some
facts
um that the rule produces and those are
named by the variables x1 prime and x2
prime on the left-hand side of the equal
sign
of course in addition we also get the
solutions to
the variables that were in our query
hopefully in the right order
all right so that was kind of a toy
example just to
go through all of the components itself
all of the the sort of
end-to-end way that it works so this is
just going to be a more
um just an example of something with
several rules
uh in the definition
uh which is uh and i'm not gonna go into
as much detail
about explaining how you set up the
initial state and run the queries
uh just just trying to describe the
rules of chess sort of the
the way that things can move and and
capture
um this isn't again this isn't uh
i guess i want to make sure that you
realize i'm not trying to describe like
a smart ai for playing chess or
something and it's
it's just um a system that describes how
the game works
okay so uh so i've
grouped pieces into three different
classes so they're they're the pieces
that move like the king and the knight
um which are basically only concerned
with their source and destination cells
uh those are kind of the easy cases then
there's the the pieces that can kind of
move arbitrary distances in any
direction
if those are free those are a little bit
more complex to code up
um they all they use the same trick um
and then there's pawns which are just
kind of weird
so i will go through this um
i don't actually play chess so i'm gonna
be embarrassed if i get something wrong
but
it like you can just pretend that i'm
talking about something
to suggest it doesn't really matter okay
um okay so
the first
why why did i lose that slide
oh my gosh this is terrible i'm sorry
ah okay well um
okay
well i can see
i can look through my album of slides
but i don't think that's
uh yeah i think i'm just gonna have to
no i i think it's we're just gonna have
to deal
um okay there were a lot of rules anyway
and it's a little bit tedious
so uh
okay no but like okay but like capturing
isn't i was gonna talk about movement
before capturing but they're basically
identical except for the parts that i
have in boxes
so um let's just let's start with
capturing
okay so let's ignore the first rule for
a sec all right
so the capture rule um
so first of all i guess this slide was
introducing the concept of turns um
so maybe i should point at the first
rule so the the way that
the rule uh the rule is structured to
allow for
swapping turns between the two colors of
players is we
we have some fact in our global state
says whose turn it is
and then we have some back retaining um
just you know simple fact that says the
colors are
opposites of each other um and then you
know we do whatever the thing is that
happens in a single turn
and then we can join um the resulting
state with the fact that the turn is now
the new color i think it's pretty
straightforward
and the capture rule so okay so we
so we need to consume this turn token
um and so when we
look at the fact i'm using occ sort for
occupied
so like the space p the position p i
guess
is occupied by king of the color color
and one hop away so we have some
separately defined backward chaining
predicate
describing the relation spatial relation
between cells
so one hop away from p is p prime
and p prime is occupied by some piece of
the opposing color
um so then we transition to it being
that color's turn and now the king is
occupying the new space p prime
and the old space p is now empty and the
piece of the new color is captured
so queen and so this kind of like
enery movement um it's a little bit
trickier
to talk about so it's actually going to
happen in three rules and this is the
first of them
so this is um just the queen committing
to a direction
that she's going to travel so the uh so
it's it's the turn is color the queen is
in the position p
of that color the
p prime is in direction der from p
and that p prime is empty so then now we
transition to
okay now the old space is empty um the
new space is occupied with the queen
and also there there's this additional
so instead of replacing
turn color with turn color prime it's
now kind of like the middle of a turn
so we have this other predicate moving
which says now the queen is moving
the queen of that color is moving along
that direction
okay these are just the remaining rules
that describe
um queen's movement so you can continue
which looks exactly like the initial
commit rule except that we
uh consume moving in a direction and we
make sure
that the new cell that we're moving to p
prime
is in that same direction that we're
already moving
um then we can stop uh which
is just taking the fact that the queen
is moving and
transitioning to the other player's turn
and finally we can capture um which
again looks looks fairly similar to the
movement rule except instead of
requiring
the uh piece that we want to move to to
be empty specified that there's a piece
there of the opposite color
and then we transition to a situation
where that piece is captured
and of course change whose turn it is
um pawn movement is
uh so this is just the the final little
like trick
that i wanted to mention just because it
requires having this extra information
that we track for each pawn
um because i think like initially you
can move it two spaces but then for the
rest of the game it can only move
one space forward um also
uh what was i gonna say
uh oh also like forward is defined
differently depending on color so
this this predicate one forward has to
uh know which color palm we're talking
about
okay so um again we we say that the
pawn of some id so also there are
multiple of them so we have to figure
out which one we're talking about
so the pawn with some id is in the space
p
uh with the color and it has not been
moved yet
um and then in that case we can
go one forward to get p prime and one
forward from
p prime to get p double prime check that
both of them are empty
and finally set up the state
so that it's now there and its status
has been set to moved
um so this is just to sort of illustrate
that like
we don't really necessarily need to
group all of the properties of a pawn
like
with like as one predicate talking about
everything it's like there are little
pieces of the state and they each get
represented by their own
predicate
okay and then this is just the simple
rule which says
no matter which state we're in we can
always move one forward
and we
as long as we make sure that
so if our status beforehand is s then we
need to make sure
that the status after the fact is moved
in any case
okay um pawn capture i think should be
straightforward enough
that you could do it with what you've
seen so far
um if that's not the case then i haven't
explained it well and maybe talk to me
afterwards
in fact okay okay so
what's the what's the result of having
if you actually go through all the links
of coding all this up
and like setting up the initial state
and figuring out how to do a query
um then what you get is actually like
tom mentioned this in his talk too uh
you get random games of chess
um i don't know if that's super
interesting but it's
uh it's it's illustrative of the point i
i do actually think it's interesting in
the sense of like
if you are designing a game as opposed
to just trying to like write down a game
someone else made
then you could do this to kind of see
what the space is um
of of available kind of playthroughs of
your game
and maybe notice some things about your
mechanics that you can tweak and
experiment with
before you you know put them up in some
fancy sequence plus system or whatever
all right so the takeaway just from this
poor
uh example part of the talk is that
linear logic programming
can be you can ignore those curly braces
sorry
the linear logic programming can be used
to
model this kind of local state on
evolving systems okay so now i want to
tell you about
like specifically what i think is cool
about this um there are a bunch of
people doing really interesting things
that i've learned a little bit about um
so linear logic
this kind of style is a lot like
planning and i know that some people
have considered it as an alternative to
planning in certain situations
lucas dixon did some work on dialogue
planning with linear logic
some other folks related to cmu henry
young and carson sherman
have used linear logic to describe
voting protocols
um published it vote id in 2011.
rob simmons has used this to describe
the operational semantics of programming
languages
using these concepts and a few of the
other ones itself has
and there's also this really cool
project that uses this
to program ensembles of um little cube
robots that can
form shapes that you specify just by you
know
performing computations locally which is
cool
um so one of the things that i've worked
on is using this for
computational narratology so this is a
field that's kind of new to me but i
i found some colleagues at t-state's
university who were doing this
um again sort of considering linear
logic as an alternative to planning
um and we used we used this system to
describe all of the narrative events in
the french novel madame bovary
and there we just had 35 linear logic
rules kind of describing the scenes of
the novel
um and then we used the we use self's
non-determinism to let this generate
random stories for us
random variations on the novel um
which is is kind of cool narrative
generation i guess is
is is a fairly um
active field and people have mostly just
kind of used these ad hoc planning
systems for it so
we were excited to try to apply linear
logic in this context
and another cool thing that we can do
with this is because the we get this
proof out which is an artifact that we
can
have structure we can analyze we can
actually
like make graphs of causality
so each of the nodes in the graph is
like some some narrative event
and and the edges are inferred by this
external system
that sort of describe which things that
happened
caused which other things that happened
and you can actually do some
additional analysis like if you run this
a bunch of times look at several of
these graphs you can analyze them for
some notion of equivalence and
similarity and then ask questions like
well in all variants of the story
did this event happen or in all variants
of the story did
this event always cause this one or
something like that
okay what i actually want to be able to
do is use this to describe
interactive fiction so we sort of used
it to describe
generated stories branching stories um
but
i i like games and interactivity and i
want to use a linear logic or some sort
of extension of these ideas
for hypertext and virtual worlds
or you can kind of think of the
interactivity as just more atoms um
being thrown into the state
when the user interacts so the sort of
first step of this would be
when you run a program to acquiescence
okay so grab the state of the world
throw in um you know take some some key
process or
some other user input um and now the
system
uh there's more rules that can fire in
the system so now run it again to
quiescence and sort of do this in an
interactive loop
um further aspirations for this
would be to kind of be able to do that
programmatically say
there are some rules over here i have
some some subset of my program over here
um that i want to run to quiescence and
then use the rules from some other part
of my program over here
throw them together and combine them
so this is a this is like adding phases
which is part of my phd work
and another thing that i'd really like
to do is add some way
of doing meta theory which is a kind of
concept from
logical frameworks where we want to
actually
write down things proofs or
write down statements that a system can
prove for us or write down proofs that
the system can check for us
that certain things always hold like a
really simple of this example of this
would be
if our rules look like this then there's
some invariant of the state which is
that there's always exactly one
of the green daughter the blue dot
and finally um i guess i'm a little bit
out of time but i
i wanted to give some historical context
to this
i didn't invent linear logic programming
i just i like it and i'm trying to
extend the ideas and use it for things
um but linear logic was uh invented in
1987 by johnny gerard prolog's been
around
since 72 and a lot of this work is
inspired by
lf which stands for logical framework so
the idea of having like a proof system
um and these ideas kind of all
influenced each other actually i
realized after the fact that this is
kind of the same form as the like
narrative causality graph that i had
drawn before um
so so these things all fed into into the
idea of clf which is the formal system
itself which is the implementation and
there's me i'm interested in narrative
interactive systems
i'm trying to put this all together
so i hope you enjoyed that and there is
code for self available that you can use
and once i get the internet working
again i'm gonna put the examples from
this talk there
and you can find me there thanks very
[Music]
much